but i used to get away with going i
can't do that i'm going to my kids suck
a game on friday so i won't be there
and then
they were like take it or leave it and i
was going through a divorce at the time
i was like i could just disappear
or i could just pay my bills and what
i'm supposed to do take the job and say
thank you very much so i was grumpy for
a little bit and they tolerated me being
in a bad mood for a year or so and then
i started to make friends and things
were wonderful
and
then they come to the end they go like
well we don't know if we can
take up your option
and i was like and i said to bob i think
it's what pissed bob off as i said
if you take me off the poster i'm not
coming back
because i don't do windows
and that was
not received well
really you just said that well yeah it's
exactly what i said because the truth
you felt like you'd earned it well the
funny thing was i mean
with all due respect to my friends i am
so grateful for myself and for all my
friends that they had work for this
amount of time it was good work and that
everybody on that crew was was just
fantastic they were all at my wedding
for god's sake yeah you know it was it
was a big deal plus the fans the fans
but the fans fans are amazing
that's that's that's without saying
but i was playing i played the same
scene in season 12 five times over five
episodes and i was like all right giggs
up you know it the gig is up
and so you know everyone's kind of had
they won't get rid of you they won't get
ready i'm like i'm done i know i'm done
you knew it yeah i know it was done
transpo
what season was this 12 12 i was killed
at the end of 12th and transpo
when
like take your car home
and when i don't have transport then
it's like we'll do it
so i took my car home like a month and a
half early two months early i was taken
to and from set every single day i was
taken home i was dropped at airports
brought back it was just
i was looked after that was sweet it is
sweet and people don't have to do that
they and they did and it was
and i think what surprised everybody on
set on my last scene is i'd already
spent two weeks saying goodbye to
everybody i didn't want to make a speech
for the first time in my life and i
think they got a little upset that i
didn't make some big speech because i'm
big mouth you didn't say anything i said
thank you very much and walked away i
spent two weeks talking to every single
person so you didn't have to say
anything i didn't feel i had to say
anything but i think it got a bit weird
and then i don't know i just do do you
get invited to the supernatural
conventions
i don't
no
you don't no i i did 17 and then it was
really weird for my friends
it was weird for my friends what do you
mean
okay so ruth plays my mother wonderful
lovely actress beautiful human being
worked her butt off on the show chris
should have been my uh
ex-wife who would have been even better
it would have been fantastic she should
have played my ex-wife in the show it
would have been just something else
right but okay she's my mom doesn't
really make sense in the can and she's
going on but we made it work and she's
just brilliant she's just wonderful to
work with
and really do i want to go to a
convention where every single question
she gets is when's mark shepard coming
back
because that's what happened for a year
yeah that's not cool
they've got work to do they've got
things to do they deserve better